bianca garibaldi and thousands of other
canadians have braved long lines and
frigid weather as omicron spreads both
the virus and a sense of urgency across
the country it's a little cold but it's
worth it to try to get a booster our
numbers are rising our icus are filling
up and it is absolutely
critical that we protect ourselves and
each other as covid case numbers rise
hospitalizations are edging upwards but
looking ahead there are signs of better
days to come omicron variant has indeed
spread quickly and exponentially the
risk of overwhelming our health care
system is real however as more canadians
contract omicron and get over it along
with increased protection from booster
vaccines it could result in a wall of
immunity that we have not produced up to
now this wave has risen faster than any
other but if it peaks then comes down
perhaps within weeks the large waves of
this pandemic could be more manageable
the virus eventually becoming endemic
something we live with like other
viruses this will be the game changer
the concerns that we had before you know
that we have big waves that overwhelm
the health care system
should not be there anymore at least not
to the same extent rather way rather
than waves we will have ripples omicron
became dominant in denmark before
christmas
yet that country's chief epidemiologist
now suggests the virus could subside
there in two months
the economy faces another bruising
winter but some businesses are looking
ahead one u.s airline is confident air
travel will bounce back by this summer
covet is now endemic we're getting
better as a society at dealing with it
accepting it and figuring out how to
manage and live our lives safely this
winter will be difficult more
restrictions more illness more deaths
but omicron may be the right formula to
see our way out of it by producing a
mild disease with lower mortality
by being much more transmissible than
other variants thereby out competing
them
it's moving itself into potentially
becoming an endemic virus there is still
reason to worry about new variants
emerging but as society's immunity
builds naturally and with vaccines there
is reason for optimism too eric sorensen
global news toronto